what's driving you crazy 6 25 on your
wednesday morning you're already tangled
up drive on charleston between maryland
parkland eastern oh man it's about to
get even funkier starting tomorrow night
at 8 and scheduled to stay shut until 8
wednesday sunday night the city of las
vegas completely shutting down
charleston and fremont that's right by
eastern it's part of their long-term
storm drain improvement project in the
area that's why charleston has those
tough lane restrictions around mountain
parkway so here are the city's suggested
detours for drivers who are northbound
on fremont or boulder highway you're
going to be coned off way back at mojave
go all the way up to stuart for
westbound travel southbound fremont
drivers from the downtown las vegas area
you'll be coned south at eastern same
goes for eastbound charleston so you go
down south on eastern to oaky that gets
you back east to fremont boulder highway
by the way westbounders on charleston
you'll be detoured north on mojave now
if you think this might affect you but
it sounds kind of like word salad this
early in the morning just check out
eightnewsnow.com you can click traffic
then driving you crazy go over it on
your own time hopefully work your way
through it buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone something's
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com